[موسيقى]
استثمر المقدسي خبرتها في العمل الحركي
والتنظيمي مع جماعه محمد سرور وسمعه
الجهاديه حصدها في افغانستان وباكستان
ليعود الى الاردن وتبدا معها مرحله تكوين
التنظيمات حيث سجن في العام 1993 مع ابو
مصعب الزرقاء وحكم عليهما بالسجن 15 سنه
بتهمه الانتماء الى تنظيم عرف باسم بيعه
الامام قبل ان يخرج المقدسي والزرقاوي من
السجن عام 1999 بعفن بعد صدور عفو العام
وفي عام 2001 القي القبض عليه مره اخرى
حتى العام 2006 في العام 2010 اصدرت محكمه
امن الدوله الاردنيه حكما بالسجن على ابو
محمد المقدس لمده خمس سنوات بعد توجيه
التهمه ملابس الشروع في مغادره الاردن
بهدف الالتحاق بجامعات المسلحه وتنظيمات
ارهابيه وجمع التبرعات لها وفي العام 2014
افرجت عنه السلطات الاردنيه قبل ان تعيد
اعتقالهم من جديد في العام نفسه لم يتردد
ابو محمد المقدسي في مقابله تلفزيونيه
اجريت مع في 2005 من يؤكد تبعيه ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي له ووفاء التلميذ الاستاذ معتبرا
انا تسميه الزرقاء لتنظيمه الاول في
العراق بالتوحيد والجهاد جاء التبنيه لنفس
الاسم لموقع المقدسي الالكتروني هذا ما
قبل الزرقاء قوي اما بعد فتحول وبمساعده
من الزرقاء الى مفتن ورمز التنظيري لكل
الجماعات المسلحه اللي حاولت ان تستخدم
الارض السلفي لتكوين جماعات قتاليه مسلحه
على غرار الزرقاوي ومن بعد تنظيم داعش لم
يحافظ عصام البرقاوي ابو محمد المقدسي على
خط واحد مع التنظيمات المسلحه الاسلاميه
الراديكاليه في سوريا والعراق مع بدايه ما
يسمى بالربيع العربي هو وصف بالمتقلب
والمتناقض من قبل مجلس شرعي لهيئه تحرير
الشام التابعه لابو محمد الجولاني وترى
اخرى بالمنتكس من قبل تنظيم داعش وزعيمه
ابو بكر البغدادي خليفه ابو مصعب الزرقاوي
المؤسس الاول لتنظيم الدوله وهو تلميذ ابو
محمد المقدسي ليرد المقدسي على التنظيم
مذكرا انا شيخهم الذي تعلموا منه التوحيد
فاود ان اعلمهم الادب وصفه ابو يحيى
الليبي القيادي العسكري في تنظيم القاعده
في كتاب بعنوان الاعمال الكامله الاعطيه
الله الليبي نشر في العام 2015
بالمتشدد والمتغالي في مسائل التكفير وفي
موقفه من العلماء بيشاروا ان سيف العدل هو
من كتب مقدمه هذا الكتاب اما عبد الله
المحيسني شارع الجماعات الاسلاميه
المسلحه في سوريا فكان احدث راي له حول
المقدسي حسب ما نراه في حسابها عبر موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ان المقدسي ليس شيخا
اصلا
بالمقابل استشهد ايمن الظواهري به في
كتابه التبريه نشر عام 2008 للتاكيد على
النهج الشرعي السليم لتنظيم القاعده
والجهاد من خلال السنادهم الى رسائل
المقدسي وانه شخصيا استفاد منه في فترات
اقامته في بشاور ووصفه بالعقليه الموسوعيه
والصمود الراسخ في وجه تواريخ العصر وعلم
من اعلام التوحيد التحق شقيق ابو محمد
المقدسي واسمها عبد العزيز المقدسي بعد
خروجه من ايران في العام 2015 بالقتال في
سوريا والعراق واعلن في تسجيل مرئي تابع
لمؤسسه البتار الاعلاميه القريبه من تنظيم
داعش تركها وتنظيم القاعده وموبايته
لتنظيم الدوله وزعيممها ابو بكر البغدادي
وطالب بالانضمام الى مشروع الخلافه وداع
شقيقه ابو محمد المقدسي بتحرر عن تنظيم
الدوله
كذلك قتل ابن ابو محمد المقدسي وهو النجم
الثاني له واسمه عمر برقاوي وعمره 25 سنه
في مدينه الموصل بالعراق في العام 2010
بعد ما التحق بالجماعات المسلحه في العراق
منذ العام 2003 وكان عمره انا ذاك 18 عاما
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعه بنتابع
في الجزء الثاني تسجيل وتدوين وقائع
ومحطات منظر تيار السلفيه الجهاديه
العالميه ابو محمد المقدسي نستضيف معنا
احد الشهود وهو الكاتب السعودي في صحيفه
الوطن استاذ محمد الدوسري حياك الله من
جديد
اه اتسد مثل
نحن نحنا بنستانف الجزء الثاني اللي نتحدث
عن علاقه ابو محمد المقدسي
عبد العزيز المعفن او من نفذ وتفجيرات
اللي عرفت بالعليا
وايضا ابغى يعني هذا طبعا بيربطنا الحديث
عن الكتابه الكواشف الجليه في كفر الدوله
السعوديه
هذا الكتاب تحديدا متى تم تداوله في
السعوديه وكيف وصل الكتاب
هذا الكتاب بدايه بدايه معرفته
[موسيقى]
148 98
وطبعا
او 90 يعني بالضبط يعني لكن
ليس لديه معلومه لكنه طبع ااا كان يتداول
هنا يدخل من طريق الكويت
وادخل ايضا اييه
همم يعني نسخ همم الكترونيه ثم تطبعين في
السعوديه مثلا pdf لانه كتاب يعني يعني
يمكن هو 200 اكثر من 200 صفحه ويطبع في
السعوديه يطلع في السعوديه يعني بامكانه
طباعه في اي مكان
لكن ادخاله بسبب ادخالهم يعني بدايه
ادخاله هنا انا
وعيت عليه في التسعينات همم يعني رايتك
الكتابه انا 90 قبل حتى قبل التسعين
الكتابه
89 ممكن الكتابه موجود لكن ادخل وكيف يعني
بصراحه ما عندي معلومه في بدايه دخوله هنا
لكن كان يدخل عن طريق يعني اذكر طبعا عن
طريق انا موجود عندي
همم يعني سحبنا الكتاب والطبع ايش قال لك
يا ابو محمد انا عن هذا الكتاب
اللي فهمته من ان يعني
ما تبقى من الدول الان كل الدول
واضح انها لديها قوانين ولا تزعم انها
تحكم بشريعه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هي التي ليس لديها قانون ليس لها قانون
مدني ولا قانون جنائي همم المحاكم تحكم
بالازال التحكم بالشريعه الاسلاميه
ولا زالت حكام البلد يعني همم يرددون
دائما انهم على عقيده السلف فهذا هو السبب
الوحيد انه يريد ان يكشف
في ما يزعل يكشف حقيقه الدوله بانها ليست
همم دوله شرعيه مرتبط بغزو العراقي
ف بالعكس هو كان يعني مالها يعني ما يؤيد
يعني اللي فهمته ما يؤيد يعني غزوه لانه
هو خسر اصلا يعني
خسروا بيوتهم لا بالاكل من موضوع التدخل
القوات
الامريكيه بانها استعانه بالامريكان فهذه
تاهيل لكن حقيقه الكتاب كان من قبل ابو
محمد المقدسي بعد غزو العراقي
كان طبعا بعد غزو ال بعد بعد احتلال
الكويت من قبل العراق بدا الناس تبحث عن
فكره
استعانه
بامريكانو بس انا بالمشركين فهذه ايضا
انتشرت وزود زعزعه وكان من ضمن المؤيدات
يعني ايضا من اسباب انه كثير من الانحراف
الشباب الفكري وذهابه من التكفير والجراه
على التكفير لان قبل قبل التسعين كان هناك
خوف كبير او انه كان العلماء لهم وزن ثقيل
جدا حتى مع وجود مملكه ابراهيم كان في بعض
الشباب نزع الى فكر محمد محمد المقدسي لكن
العلماء لهم ثقل ولما هيك كبار العلماء في
السعوديه لهم ثقل كبير لكن بعد دخول بعد
غزوه الكويت
رجعت كفه كتب المقدسي هل كان هناك في
الشباب
الي صارت اسمها السلفيه الاصلاحيه اللي هو
مكان التيار السروري في السعوديه بدايه
بزوغ نجمهم في هذه الفترات ابو محمد
المقدسي هل التقاطع يعني كان في نقل
التقارات مع عناصر مثلا منهم او من
السلفيين الجهادين مثلا سليمان العلوان
سفر الحوالي سلمان العوده
يعني همم
يعني
علاقه ابو محمد فيما بعد يعني بعد ما ما
ادري ما اعرف علاقه لكن سليمان العلوان كم
الاخوان بريده اصلا ما ما لها علاقه
لكنهما هؤلاء
التغير اللي حدث عن سليمان العلوان هذا
فيما بعد في 2003 بعد غزوه بعد غزو
الامريكان للعراق
في امريكا
هل في تاكيد يعني
ما خرج من السعوديه
في كفر الدوله وذهبوا الى ما يذهب الى ابو
محمد بل انه يعني كانوا يؤيدون كل جميع ما
يستدل بها انا سمعت جميع ما يستدل سليمان
العلوان هو حقيقه كل كلام ابو محمد
المقدسي يعني ادله محمد المقدسي الموجوده
في العامل المشترك وهذه حقيقه كثير من
الباحثين ما يريدن يعني ان يبينها العامل
المشترك بينهم كتب امه الدعوه الجديده
التكفير منبع الاصلي من كتب النجديه
ولولا وجود استدلالات وادله من كتب محمد
من ائمه لا قيمه الكتاب ابراهيم ابدا بدون
استدلالات يعني لو نحذف استدلالاته بكلامه
الدعوه ما قيمه ليس له قيمه لكنه ولذلك
جميع حتى الشيخ الشعيبي وكذا في ما بعد
كلهم تقاطع مع محمد المقدسي بسبب
بسبب
بسبب كتب
والا يعني والا كان يعني ليس له وزن لولا
كتب ائمه الدعوه
لذلك هو فيما بعد
الحادثه اللي ذكرتيها انت كان يعني كان له
تاثير شديد جدا اما في يعني تقاطعه مع
السوريين انا ما اعرف انها يعني التقاء
لكن السوريين اصبحوا اصلا يميلون لان
السوريين يعني اخذوا يظهرون عدم الولاده
الدوله يعني مثلا في في حادثه في التسعين
محاضره السفر الحوالي اللي تكلم فيها عن
الغزو الامريكي
يعني كانها يعني رساله يعني كانها صوره
مصغره من كثره ابراهيم المحاضره اللي اللي
ذكرها في اللي اللي القاها في جامعه الملك
خبر اكيد انه التقى
قبل قبل يمكن في ايام ايام
الغزو
العراقي طيب يعني
بمناسبه حديثنا عن سفر الحوالي كان ابو
محمد كان هناك تزام بين كتاب لابو محمد
المقدسي وسفر الحوالي همم واللي هو همم
كان بعنوان بتاع النظر في كشف شبهات برج
العقرب العصفر ابو محمد المقدسي وفي نفس
الوقت كان في كتاب ايضا للسرور يسافر
الحوالي ظاهره الارجاء في الفكر الاسلامي
همم وكمان طبعا السفر
في مسائل التكفير بشكل
[موسيقى]
دكتوراه وكان معجب فيها المقدسي
وكان التوافق هو توافق فكري
وتوافق روحي
يعني مشرب
فهم سيد قطب
للحاكميه والبراء هو نفس المشرب اللي
يغترف منه سفر الحوالي وكذلك محمد المغربي
محمد المقدسي
وعزز الفكره هذه بكلامه الدعوه النجديه
بيفهمه هو تاوي كده انها تدل على
[موسيقى]
وكلاهما سفر الحوالي ومحمد المقدسي يتفقون
في على فكره
العصر اللي هم يقصدون فيه الشيخ الالباني
ومن يعني ومن نحوه في ان همم الخلاف بينهم
في العمل العمل انه ترك العمل ليس كفره
هذا هو الخلافه هذا الخلافه الكبير بينهم
في الايمان لان الايمان عند السفر الحوالي
ومن ابو محمد المقدسي انه يقوله عمل وفعل
ولذلك تارك العمل
يكفر بالنسبه لمثل تارك الصلاه وغيره تارك
الحكم وغير يكفر اما بالنسبه للشيخ
الالباني لا يكفر تارك الصلاه ولا يكفر
الا بالجحود هذا هذا خلاف قوي جدا بينهم
الان
ولذلك يعني صار توافق بين سفر وبين
ابو محمد
بعد ذلك عزيزه الشيخ سفر الحوالي في دروس
في شرح الطحاويه
لكن الان ااه بالنسبه لابو محمد المقدسي
فيما بعدنا شفت له مؤلفات وكذا كلها يتكلم
على مرجات العصر ويقصد لانه في في لانه
كان متواجد وايضا متواجد علي عبد الحميد
علي حسن عبد الحميد كلهم اللي هم اصحاب
الالباني موجودين في الاردن
في الكويت كتابه كشف النقاب عن شريعه
الغاب هو يقول وان بين في هذا الكتاب
تكفيره لحكومه للنظام الكويتي
ايش تذكر يعني
كله كلام يدور حول الدخول
البرلمانات ايه مجلس الامه وكان من ضمنها
انه يبين لهم ان ان الحكومه الكويتيه تحكم
غير ما انزل الله بدي السور لوضع عبد بصي
على عبد الله سالم وايضا كذلك تحكم
بقوانين وضعيه فلذلك يعني
وكان لا يقبل تاويلات جمعيه الحياه التراث
في انهم يدخلون البرلمان فكان وذكر هو في
احدى كتب نص صراحه انه يكفر الدوله
الكويتيه وكده يعني الصراحه من هذا بيقدني
اني اسالك على موضوع محاولات او مشاركه
محمد ابو محمد المقدسي مع مجموعه من
المتطرفين في الكويت بتفجير مركز الفنون
في منطقه السالميه للممثل للفنان الكويتي
عبد الحسين عبد الرضا ايش تذكر لي عنها
ما يعني ما عندي معلومات دقيقه عنها ولا
يعني ولا استطيع ان اتحدث
الا فيما بعد سمعت انها تنسب اليه محمد
المقدسي كده ودي كده الايام كنا نعرف ان
اللي وراءها ابو محمد المقدسي لكن ليس
معلومه لانه منتج انت سبب الخبر
تعرف في نفسي
هو وراء اللي فجرو وكانوا من ضمن يعني كنا
نسمع فيها لكن ما كنا يعني
ما كنا عندنا معلومات دقيقه عنها يعني طيب
هو يعني بحسب ما تذكر الاخبار انها كانت
اصدرت الكويت حكم غيابي على ابو محمد
المقدسي هل هو خرج من الكويت امت روح يعني
يعني غادرها تم ترحيله ام كيف وكيف كان
وضعه مغادره الكويت اذا تذكر اياها
انا كنت متواجد في الكويت
سنه كم
[موسيقى]
قبل احتلال الكويت
89 او 88
فكنت انا اذكر انه كان يعني
ياخذ يعني يلملم شمله ويلملم اهله ويلملم
اثاث ونقل بعض اثاره
يمكن نسيت لكنه كانه انه تم ترحيله من
الكويت امم لكن السبب ما اعرف السبب ايش
السبب الحقيقي يعني ما عندي لكني عندي
اتذكر انه كان هناك ترحيل له هذا الكلام
لكن بدقه قبل احتلال الكويت 88 او 89 هو
ارحل الاردن تم ترحيل الاردن الاردن
[موسيقى]
واحد من بقايا الاخوان شهر بنهد موجود في
الزلفي التقى فيه
وذكره كبيره انا لحقت عليه عمره فوق
التسعيني
ليش بحث عنهم
مؤيدات
لان هذه الدوله يعني فيها خداع ونفاق وكذب
انه قتلت الاخوان هو لان هذا كان شارب
وكان يتبنى فكره هذه الملك قتل الاخوان
وتابع هذا موجود في البحوث منتشره عن
البحوث تاريخيه يعني لكن خلال
السبب قاتلهم هذا الكلام
غدا او قتلهم بسبب خروجهم على همم الامر
هذه المساله اخرى لكن هو كان يتبنى هذا
الفكر شاهر ولذلك هذا من المؤيدات انه
يبين ان هذه الدوله
يعني فيها كذب من خلال تبنيها الفكره اما
تدعو النجديه وهي تعمل بخلافه من ضمنها
مثلا قتل الدعاه من ضمنها وجود الربا وهو
ذكرها في الكتاب وجود وجود صلح الربا
البنوك طبعا هذه كلها مسائل فقهيه هو ممكن
يناقش فيها لكن
سببه حتى يؤيد لان هو متبني فكره التكفير
متبني
نزعت فكره التكفير المتبناه لدى همم لديه
من قبل
متشرب الحقيقه متشرف بفكر سيد قطب همم
متشرده مره
تعزيز لكنه سيد قطب مؤثر عليه جدا هو ذكر
على انه هذا الشخص سيد ااا سيد سيد عيد
يوسف انه حجم تاثيره عليه
يعني لكن تعرف فكره السيد سعيد
ديك الفتره هل كان في رجال دين علماء يعني
على الساحه كان يتناظر معهم ابو محمد
المقدسي
يعني ما اذكر يعني بالعكس كان يبتعد يعني
اللي انا اللقاءات اللي كان يجيني ما فيه
هنا ما كان يعني
في السعوديه هنا وجانا هنا بالعكس كان
يبتعد عنه لانه يعتبرهم انهم يشتغلهم
مخابرات
كان عنده حذر شديد لانها تعرف ان كان يدخل
مزوره ويخشى النهد يعرفها يعني همم فكان
يبتعد عن اي مكان احد يعرف فيه حتى دخول
الى السعوديه كانت بالجوازات الاصليه
لان يدخل الجواز كويتي
يعني هل تحلق حول المقدسي في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يعني ايام معدوده يعني
ايام معدوده جدا
فما ما اظن يعني ما اظنها القدروس ولا اظن
احد يعني كل التاثير هو كده يعني عن
طريق كتاب ابراهيم طيب بالنسبه الانتماء
لاهل الحديث السابق محمد
اطراف مختلفه واحيانا متناقضه مثل عندنا
احنا همم طرف ابو زرقاوي وابو محمد
المقدسي وهم بيتبنوا تكفير الحكومات ورفع
سلاح
ضد
الحكومات ورفع سلاح ويطلق عليهم
بالاسم مثلا المداخله او الجاميه
فلماذا تتنازع هذه التيارات الانتساب
لمسمى اهل الحديث
والله هذا النزاه كله البحث عن الشرعيه
كلهم يبحث عن شرعيه لانك انت ومشروعيه اذا
انت يعني وصلت بانك من هالحديث فانت تتزعم
اهل السنه وانت ليس من اهل البدع
ويترتب على ذلك جميع استدلالات تكون صحيحه
متوافقه مع من الكتاب والسنه
فكل الجميع هذه التيارات سواء المداخله
سواء الجميع سواء يعني السلفيه الالبانيه
سواء السلفيه الجهاديه او سواء اهل الحديث
اللي يتبناه جهيمان جميع هذه الاطراف
وكذلك اذا سلفيه الشيخ
همم
الشيخ ربيع بن هادي والشيخ والشيخ اللي في
اليمن الشيخ همم
كل هذه الاطراف ايضا حتى في في انا اذكر
في صنعاء انا رحت صنعه ايضا هناك السلفيه
في تبنوا اهل الحديث
الشيخ مقبل الوادي في في اليمن كذلك جميع
هذه التيارات تتبنى فكره انه منها الحديث
البحث عن مشروعيه الشرعيه
المقدسي يقول انا ممثل اهل السنه وانا
ممثل الفكر الصحيح
وما عدايه هو يعني يمثل فكر غير يعني
يختلف عن فكر اهل السنه والفهم الحقيقي هي
جميع
خلافات
طبعا فيما بعد طبعا
كل من لم يخرج من بوتقه هذه الخلافات لن
يرى من يرى الفكر الاخر هذه مشكله كبيره
جدا وهذا هو اللي استفدناه احنا لما خرجنا
من الفكره هذا سنراه من بعيد فلما ترشي من
بعيد تراه بوضوح اوسع بشكل اوسع فترى هذه
جميع هذه التيارات الان جوابها واحد يبحث
عن مشروعيه هذه الطيارات تبحث عن مشروعيه
الجاميه يقول حنا نحن نمثل السلف همم
المداخل يمثلون السلف المقبل الواد يمثل
السلف الالباني يقول انا انا ممثل الاسلام
والسلف جميع هؤلاء هل يعقل ان في همم ما
نريد ان ينتقل لكن انا اوصف وصفا جميع هذه
التيارات تبحث عن مشروعيه وسببها انها
واذا كذلك من يتبع يكبر العلماء هنا يقول
انا ممثل همم اهل الحديث
فهذا هو البحث عن مشروعيه فقط
عندها في الجزء الاول وهي علاقه ابو محمد
المقدسي بمنفذي التفجيرات العليا عبد
العزيز الي بعثتهم
عاش اسماعيل
وعرفت رجل بسيط جدا يعني قد وصلنا لرجل
عامه حتى مش طالب عنده
همم
وكذلك خالد السعيد عرفت عن قرب يعني ورياض
الهاجري كذلك للشمراني ما عرفته ولا قبل
لكن هؤلاء الثلاثه عرفتم عن قرب وخصوص
المعتم عرفت عن قرب يعني قرب
قريب مره يعني كان يذهب معي ويروح معي لكن
بعد ما تركت الخوانه فيما بعد
سمعت انه طبعا انه كان راح الاردن
الدوله
البسيط جدا لكن في ما بعد كيف تبنى الفكر
طبعا رياض السيد وخالد الهادي كانوا من
شباب افغانستان
[موسيقى]
صغار جدا
عمره 17 18 سنه صغير جدا
حمل السلاح وقاتل
ما قاتل ولا يعرف ولا يعرف شيء عن القتال
لكنه فكريا
كانوا متشرف بفكر من ليله ابراهيم
بجميع ما يقول محمد ابو محمد المقدسي حتى
قبل ما يعرف هذا الكلام في في العهد اللي
انا كنت فيه موجود فيما بعد عاد انا سمعت
مثل ما سمعت انه انه قابل محمد المقدسي
وكذا وتاثر لكن تاثره
هي في 96 وفي ال 95 لكنه بتاثر من قبل من
90 هل هو لقاء واحد يعني جماعه همم
مين مين مين كمان
اللي قرات انا في الجرائد يعني والتحقيقات
ان ذهب وجلاسم عند ذهبوا الى الاردن
[موسيقى]
قبل
قبل التفجير هذا رايت عبد العزيز المعتم
ورياضه الهاجري وخالد السعيد في احدى
المكتبات في السويدي
وكان صديق لي ولكن لاني انا تعرفين
الاخوان عندهم اللي يتركهم يهجرون
ويعتبروك انك يعني نضال وكذا
المكتبات وكذا فصد عني يعني ولا سلم عليه
ولا شيء
ماشي
هل انك فكره اذا كانوا بايعين لاسامه بن
لادن احد قيادات تنظيم القاعده بذكر بان
الشباب السعودي والشباب عامه العربي اللي
جاء في المرحله المبكره في افغانستان هناك
كانوا اعطوا بيعات سريه لاسامه بن لادن
وان يعودوا لتنفي
اذا كانوا صغار ما اظن حتى اسامه التعامل
معهم لكن
المعثم ما اظن لكنهم يعني لديهم الاستعداد
لكن ما ما عندي معلومه ولا اظن المعظم
ممكن هذه كلها جاهز لكن ما عندي معلومه
منهم بايعه
ابغى اسالك سيد محمد المقدسي كان هل
التفاست كانت هناك مفاصله بيني وبين جماعه
الجهيمان يقال انه وقع خلاف بيننا وبين
بقايا الجماع
موجود خلاف التكفير الدول وكذا موجوده
وموجود في خلافه احدى كبار الاخوان هناك
اسمه عبد الله الدوسري
عبد الله الغانم موجود في الكويت وكان هذا
يعني
بس يعني مالها ذكر هذا لكن كانوا فاصلين
يعني ابو محمد المقدسي انه على انه ضال
لا لا انه بين المفاصله يعني مفصله في
المواقف يعني
في هذه في فتره التسعينات لا تعرفها انا
فعلا انه
كان يعني ما كان يظهرها ابو محمد ما كان
يظهرها المقدسي لا كان يجتمعون ان الاخوان
كثير لا يريدون ان لكن هي ممكن تحصل
نقاشات بتحصل مفاصله يعني
لا ما اظن عداله لان الاخوان اللي بقايا
جهيمان يحاولون يجمعون لما الشتات اصلا
لان كانوا متفرقين اصلا كانوا قله
ما يعني ما اظن بقى منهم احد يعني ما ما
اعرف انه بقى منهم حتى في الكويت اسال انا
لي فتره انا يمكن اكثر من 40 سنه ما راح
اتفقنا من اخرتها لكنها همم اسمع انهم ليس
لهم بقايا ما احد بقى منه موجودين هنا
موجودين في السعوديه
موجودين
هل هم على الفكر
ما اظن على فكره تغير هو موجود بعضهم
موجود في السجن في السجن لانه
تاثر التسعينات
اييه جزء منهم تبني فكره الدوله اللي هم
الان في السجن
والدخول في يعني عدم تكفير
الدورين الجزء منهم
لازال يعني تركبك جهيمان ما وصل للتكفير
ما كفر الدوله هؤلاء تخطوا
لابو محمد المقدسي تخطى فكري وجميع
الجماعات اللي تشوفينها الان في سوريا
وسواء داعش اصولها نواتها الحقيقيه من
اللي ابراهيم
حتى في القاعده اللي يقول احنا القاعده
النواتهم الحقيقيه
في معسكر حتى لا يغضب الشباب او يغضب منه
الشباب السعودي
ابراهيم الاخضر
من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ثم الحديث ثم همم
[موسيقى]
لا والله اللي رايتنا منه رجال بصير انسان
بسيط جدا متواضع فيه تواضع هذا اللي يعرف
اللي شفته
متواضع وبسيط ورجل يعني حتى من ناحيه
الدنيا يا رجل فقير يعني معدم يعني ما
عندهم
ورجل ما هو صاحب دنيا يعني في كثير من
الاخوان يعرفهم عن اصحاب الجنه
تاثر اسلاميه ثم تدرج في الفكر واجهه حتى
حصل لان من يعلق فيه فكره سيد قطب خصوصا
من يقرا في تفسير الظلال ويعلق في ذهنه
معالم في الطريق صعب يتخلص منه عززه
بوجودك في بيئه يمكن لو كان في السعوديه
يمكن كان صعب عليه لكن بيئه خصبه في
الكويت فيها تعدديه فيها فيها حريه في
الطرح الاراء فيها ولا يوجد هناك علماء
يعني ضابطين البلد هنا السعوديه هي تكبر
العلماء وكان انا ذاك ال الشيخ عبد العزيز
بن باز الله يرحمه الشيخ ابن عثيمين كان
هم اللي ماسكين
ترى من اسباب من اسباب عدم اقتحام لان
اقتحمت بقوه من ابراهيم لكن من كان يصدها
كان يصدها الشيخ ابن عثيمين وما لهم
الشعبيه والشيخ الشيخ عبد العزيز بن باز
وما لهم الشعبيه وكذلك ايضا سفر سفر كان
يصد في فتره التكفيل كان يمانع من التكفير
يعني التكفير اللجوء فكره تكفير الجمال
همم الحكام وكذا في فتره من الفترات يعني
وكذلك سلمان العوده يعني هذه الحق يقال
كان في ذكر الفتره كانها ولا يصدون من عدم
تاثر الشباب بمنله ابراهيم يمكن مشاريع
لهم مثل سلمان وسفر لكن اما بالنسبه للشيخ
ابن عثيمين الشيخ ابن باز كان هو السبب
الحقيقي وراء يعني عدم انتشار من عندنا
تشرد لكنه
لولا الله ثم وجود الشيخ ابن عثيمين ابنها
اثر كبير جدا في همم
جعل الشباب انهم يحيطون
همم بفكر الشيخ قال له تاثير لكن بعد ما
ذهب الشيخان
يعني همم صارت الساحه
مفتوحه ولا ولا يعني لم لم ياتي بديل لهما
همم
هل الزرقاء كانس يعني سهم وهو اللي يعزز
في صعود اسم همم ابو محمد المقدسي سعيد
[موسيقى]
بعد دخول الامريكان للعراق يعني
تداول يعني اي يعني
حتى اللي خرجوا من هنا كثير منهم تاثر
بفكر او بدايه يتاثر بالفكره من بيت
ابراهيم ثم عاد يذهب الى ساحه الجهاد ساحه
الجهاد مفتوح
تردد على التكفير يكون تكفير حتى مركب في
تعدد الجماعات وخصوصا المقدسيه
المقدسي له تاثير كبير على جميع الان يعمل
في الجهاز
الوقت بشكل مبكر قوي من خلال ابو محمد
ابو محمد المقدسي الزرقاوي ما انتشر هذا
الانتشار الا بسبب تمسك بفكر همم
كنت يعني سمعت باسم الزرقاء وفي ذلك الوقت
بعد بعد احتلال العراق العراق وبعد
تكوين جماعه في القاعده ما ادري شو اسمها
ولا سمعته
ابدا
وابغى اسالك هل تعتقد ان هناك جهد رسمي او
ما هو رسمي
مؤسسي لمواجهه كتاب او ما طرح ابو محمد
الوقت يصير في كتابه ابراهيم والكواشف
الجليه
والله هذا سؤال يعني من اهم الاسئله
الحقيقه هو الذي ينبغي ان يكون يؤرق كثير
من الباحثين والمفكرين والمؤسسات الفكريه
الموجوده في السعوديه
لان كتاب مله ابراهيم لم يواجه مؤسسيا
مواجهه حقيقيه
بحيث انه يفنى التفنيدا حقيقيا ويبين
للناس الخطا الموجود فيه
وسبب سبب عدم الخوف من مواجهته لانه يسوق
ادله من كتب ائمه الدعوه النجديه وهذا
يقودنا البحر
في الخطا الحقيقي اذا كنت يعني انا استغرب
من الجماعات اللي تقول احنا من اهل الحديث
وابحثون من اهم المشروعيه اللي احنا
عايشينهم انه عدم التقليد والبحث عن
الدليل وانه ل- لا حجه في قول احد يقول
الله عز وجل يقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
كان هذه جميع جميع الجهات تقول هذا الكلام
وتتمنى وجميع من نسمعه يقول حين الحجه في
الكتاب والسنه اذا ايضا
لا يوجد معصوب لابد من بحثه لا يمكن هذا
معتقد وهذا اللي مقتنع فيه لا يمكن
تبيين الخطا والخلل
والضلال الموجود في كتاب مله ابراهيم الا
من خلال بيان الخطا الموجود الذي تبناه
مثل الدعوه الجديد
وكثير من القضايا الفكريه سواء في التكفير
المعين سواء في في بعض الافعال التكفيريه
التي تبناها من الدعوه النجديه سواء بدايه
الشيخ محمد عبد الوهاب حتى الشيخ سليمان
محمد بن ابراهيم هذه
الفتاوى لابد ان تدرس
يبين الخلل فيها
وايضا مساء العذر بالجهل هذه كلها هذه
نزال تداول عند الشباب من بدايه الشاب في
التكفير اول يبحث مساج عذر بالجهل يقول
والله ما في عذر بالجهل اذا قال هذا
الكلام خاص انتهى بدا يكفر الناس وهذا
خطوره يعني شاب صغير عمره 17 18 سنه والله
انت كافر ليه كافر قبل
الان يعني من خلال حياتنا الان وجدت ناس
في احكام كثيره ما يعرفها ولا يفهمها اصلا
وهناك وكل ما تعمق الانسان يعني
يعني مثلا يعني فكره ان تكون اللي يقول
وهذا موجود في كلام امهات الدوله الحجه
انك اذا قرات القران على الانسان خالص
اقامه الحجه
كثير من الناس مثقفين ادبا تقرا عليه بعض
رائحه ما يفقها اصلا
وهذه اشكال لهذه المشكله
ائمه الدعوه النجديه وبيان الخلل والخطا
فيها هو الذي
قبول
ابراهيم طيب حضرتك استاذ محمد وانا عارف
انك منخرتنا نوعا ما في بعض الجهود في
موضوع الامن الفكري وما الى ذلك كيف تشوف
شباب اليوم هل هم محصنين من التاثر مله
ابراهيم هلا لمست رغم ما في تغيرات في
السعوديه والانفتاح هناك تاثر لازال
ابراهيم
يعني
مثلا يسموه الامريكيه عقوله بسطحيه جدا
يعني مهتمين بالموسيقى والفن والترفيه
وكذا لكن
ببساطه
لان اصلا هو مش محسن فكريين هو هذا الشاب
البسيط اللي يتنطط في الموسيقى وكذا لو
جاءتها فتره ايمانيه
لحظه لحظه ايمانيه سوف ينقلب تكفيليا
يعني قد الشاب الصغير لما ينخرط مثلا في
الموسيقى ولا لكن تجيه لحظه ايمانيه نفحت
ايمانيه التوبه يعني بدا يعني الرجوع الى
الله وهذا موجود وهذا الرجوع هو ببساطه قد
يكون اما ان ايي واللي يشوفها الان لانه
لما يراه
الفكر الان نجلس مع الناس هي الموسيقى
تسمع موسيقى وتحب الموسيقى لكنها لما تيجي
حكم الشرع استغفر الله حرام
كيف حرام يا اخي انت قاعد تسمعها انت لابد
تتبنى فكر لما تكون حلال
وتكون ما عندك مشكله في سماع الموسيقى
والتمثيل
لك هذه المسائل ما حررت حتى حتى ثقافيه
يعني حتى المسرح موجود
موجود لكنه
موجود
يا شباب انفتحوا ولكن لا يوجد مصالحه مع
هذا الكتاب
ابراهيم فكره التكفيل فكره الميل للتطرف
لا زالت بذره موجوده
وباسرع وقت تنفجر
طيب انا اتوقف عند هذه النقطه جدا مهمه
واللي تحتاج الى احاديث كثير طويله طيب
اسمح لي السيد محمد
معك هذا الحديث ابو محمد المقدسي من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين الى محمد سرور وتنظيم
سيد قطب وصولا الى اهل الحديث واخيرا
جماعه جهيمان هي مجموعه من الافكار
والمعتقدات نسيت خيوطها في شبكه واحده لا
نهايه لها هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]